au nord de la californie à san francisco
un français est en train de bâtir un
petit empire
ça va alors ça prend forme
cette boulangerie artisanale de 250 m²
et la dernière créée par pascal rigaud
ça va bien
ce bordelais de 55 ans joue gros il a
investi plus de 600000 euros dans cette
boutique
pourtant à quelques heures de
l'ouverture prévue demain matin
rien n'est prêt alors le patron met la
main à la pâte
je fais semblant de bosser quand on a
beau se préparer et toujours à la
dernière minute c'est vrai c'est
toujours pareil ça va être vraiment
jusque sur le fil
boulanger on s'est fendu pascal c'est
que son meilleur argument de vente et
son savoir faire made in france
sans oublier une touche d'authenticité
des affiches de vieux films français
sont placardées aux murs les meubles ont
été artificiellement vieillie et les
grandes tables rustique créé la
convivialité
j'ai fauté le seul à fond vraiment ah
oui tu as des cicatrices pour le prouver
j'ai des égratignures partout sur genou
à san francisco la culture et la
gastronomie française ont le vent en
poupe
chaque ouverture d'une boulangerie de
pascal rigaud est un événement dans
l'avenir on ouvre demain matin à 7
heures demain matin vous êtes le
propriétaire
oui c'est vraiment chouette d'ignorer
que ça ouvrait demain 7h demain
oui on se balade et bien je vous attends
si l'engouement est tel c'est parce que
pascal n'est pas un boulanger comme les
autres ont en quelques années celui que
les américains ont surnommé le steve
jobs de la boulangerie a connu un succès
fulgurant
à 25 ans pascal rigaud alors simple
boulanger dans le sud-ouest de la france
décide de tenter sa chance en californie
quinze ans plus tard il a créé sa propre
marque et possède 22 boulangerie à san
francisco
connu pour sa baie sublime et ses rues
escarpées san francisco et la ville
américaine la plus ouverte aux cultures
étrangères
l'explosion de la silicon valley voisine
attirer toute la région vers le haut le
petit frenchie a profité de ce cocktail
détonnant entre une économie qui explose
et le goût des habitants pour les
saveurs venues d'ailleurs
c'est la meilleures boulangeries de la
ville c'est fantastique la qualité est
vraiment excellente 6ème la pâtisserie
française
les croissants les macarons en quelques
années
pascal rigaud est devenu le pape de la
pâtisserie au point qu'en 2012
le géant du secteur starbucks lui offre
100 millions de dollars pour acheter son
business et langages comme directeur du
département nourriture pour tous les
états unis où on va on fait tous les
quatre quarts toute la gamme de petits
coups qui tout et nous quoi il supervise
plus de 12000 boutique de savoir faire
français c'est cheval de troie pour un
forum des produits américains moyens un
délicieux
aujourd'hui pascal rigaud et le
boulanger le plus riche des états unis
il y a 6 mois pourtant il s'est lancé un
nouveau défi créer une autre chaîne de
boulangeries et partir à l'assaut de la
grande distribution
[Musique]
dans la célèbre baie de san francisco
les premiers touristes profitent du
lever de soleil sur le port
[Musique]
à quelques encablures dans le centre
l'ambiance est plus agitée c'est le
moment de vérité pour pascal rigaud sa
toute nouvelle boulangerie ouvre ses
portes dans quelques minutes seulement
[Musique]
avec un loyer de plus de 10000 euros et
une dizaine de salariés
parce qu'elle doit vendre au moins 1500
produits par jour pour que cette
boutique soit rentable
pascal tu veux tourner le store je le
fais guillaume un français de 39 ans est
le manager de la boulangerie c'est parti
quand on ouvre le store et l'éclaireur
césar - 6h50 un deux trois boulangeries
[Applaudissements]
7 heures du matin mais jean la
boulangerie ouvre officiellement ses
portes et 30 minutes plus tard
l'odeur du pain chaud semble avoir gagné
tout le quartier
joyau mardi tout le monde les commandes
pleuvent et les cinq vendeurs sont vite
débordés ils serviront plus de 200
clients dans la matinée de 0,25 s'il
vous plaît vous trouverez le lait de
soja sur le comptoir derrière vous c'est
toujours sympa d'avoir un café dans son
quartier la majorité d'entre eux sont là
avant tout pour la signature pascal
rigaud
la star des boulangers il y a du bon
café du chocolat chaud et des bonnes
viennoiseries la gastronomie française
est très populaire ici passe-passe
servait à la tension agresseurs
on est content chez un boulanger combler
tout le monde respire en mai valait
vraiment lors de cette première journée
la boulangerie de pascal écoulera plus
de 1500 pièces soit près de 5000 euros
de chiffre d'affaires
pari gagné encore une fois en moins de
deux mois
pascal a déjà ouvert cinq nouvelles
boulangeries dans les lieux stratégiques
du centre de san francisco bonjour
comment ça va pour optimiser les coûts
le boulanger français à créer une
cuisine centrale avec 40 employés qui se
relaient aux fourneaux 24 heures sur 24
7 jours sur 7
si tu comptes toutes les pièces de
viennoiseries etc etc ça à peu près
entre entre 5 et 7 mai les produits du
sort par jour tous les jours des grands
classiques de la boulangerie française
mais pas uniquement pour faire face à la
concurrence et surprendre sa clientèle
pascal propose chaque mois de nouvelles
recettes sucrées ou salées mais là on
est en train de goûter des nouveaux
produits là c'est par exemple c'est une
base de pâte à croissant un peu
d'oignons de la tomate un peu de
mozzarella dessus lassé il ya des pommes
de terre il ya des oignons si ça marche
c'est des produits qui vont aller
dans les magasins dans l'est dans les
quelques jours qui viennent quoi et
c'est parce qu'à lui-même qui teste les
recettes de ces chefs pâtissiers en
quelques bouchées il doit déterminer si
le produit peut séduire le palais des
américains
verdict pas mal ça manque un peu de peps
l'un des secrets de sa réussite être
parvenu à mélanger deux cultures
gastronomiques que l'on pourrait croire
incompatibles cette parfaite avec
comment s'appelle des canneberges des
airelles un petit crumble dessus c'est
délicieux c'est un 4/4 revisité ont fait
un petit gâteau aussi à la purée de
citrouille
tout ça c'est ben oui ça date un petit
peu mieux en ni quand même rajoute nos
caractéristiques française c'est les
américains qui achète quoi c'est
toujours ça à faire merci beaucoup merci
chaque mois pascal renouvelle 10% de sa
gamme de pâtisseries à san francisco ce
français a réussi à créer une
institution
il est devenu un des entrepreneurs les
plus respectés et les plus riches de la
ville alors il ya six mois il s'est payé
un plaisir à la hauteur de son
portefeuille une villa dans le
prestigieux quartier de seacliff sur les
hauteurs de la ville
sharon stone robin williams le pdg de
twitter et des stars du football
américain vivent tous ont vécu ici c'est
les chantiers de nouvelles maisons qu'on
se fait construire
pascal est plus préoccupé par ces
affaires que par sa nouvelle maison
il n'est pas au courant que la lame est
déjà en état de marche
il y en a une ou pas ou qu'est ce qu'il
faut que j'appelle même et ça ça
sonnerait et quelques secondes plus tard
mais parce que je voulais voir
d'engagement montré un truc
une sirène digne d'une alerte anti
aérienne résonne dans tout le quartier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça y est ok dans moins de deux mois
le boulanger français doit emménager
dans cette ville à 2 500 mètres carrés
sur trois étages 5 chambres
4 quatre salles de bain chaud chantal
salle de bains grand living room une
grande famille l'hérault ça c'est un
ascenseur qui était qui étaient là quand
on a quand on a acheté la maison on va
le garder c'est pour mais pour mes vieux
jours
ah ouais c'est vraiment la maison de mes
rêves mais c'est la maison avec cette
maison parce qu'elle est avant tout
choisi pour son emplacement
ça c'est pas mal quand tu te réveilles
le matin tu voi golden gate fait quand
même c'est bon pas
avoir le privilège de se lever tous les
matins face aux golden gate à un prix
qui n'est pas à la portée de tous
haas a coûté 6 millions qu'on a à peu
près quelque chose comme ça va mais
c'est beaucoup d'argent quoi c'est
énormément d'argent et après tu mets tu
mets une belle cuisine ça va vite après
les défenses c'est juste comme les
américains disent à nice tu à nice to
have une fois les travaux achevés les
meubles et la décoration installé le
prix de la villa atteindra les 7
millions de voeux en attendant sa vue
imprenable sur le golden gate
pascal et sa famille sont hébergées par
des amis dans un autre quartier
le dimanche est le seul jour de repos du
boulanger français
le seul jour où il peut profiter de sa
femme et de son fils de 14 ans général
c'est pas trop le truc le petit déj moi
je passe par de bonnes heures puis je
vais bouffer toute la journée donc en
général j'en prends pas on est on est
nourri aux produits de la boulange
l'état dur c'est du solide
il y a trente ans pascal à rencontrer
virginie à los angeles
ensemble ils ont bâti un empire mais dit
avoir gardé les pieds sur terre on est
toujours aussi heureux notre vie n'a pas
changé
juste un autre compte en banque malgré
cette fortune qui dépasse les 100
millions d'euros parce qu'elle ne mène
pas grand train il préfère rester
discret à un détail près complètement
électrique
mais bon ça coûte la peau des fesses
accord j'adore
passionné par l'écologie pascal a craqué
pour ce bolide 100% électrique à 100000
euros
un concentré de technologie
elle a un système de pilotage
automatique complet c'est à dire que ça
reconnaît les voitures qui a devant
qu'il ya derrière sur le côté il suffit
de rentrer les paramètres de mettre
l'endroit où on veut aller et je peux
maintenant derrière
il s'agit pour l'instant de l'unique
voiture homologuée capable de conduire
seul sur une autoroute et du véhicule
électrique le plus puissant de la
planète
c'est la voiture sur près de zéro à 120
kilomètres heure qui est la plus rapide
en accélération c'est une accélération
de malades les regarde
[Musique]
le boulanger français travaille 12
heures par jour et il s'octroie
seulement une demi journée de détente
par semaine on va les taper quelques
balles dans un endroit extraordinaire
exceptionnelle aujourd'hui une partie de
golf en plein coeur de san francisco
c'est incroyable comme endroit ça vu ça
c'est là je crois que ça a été trop avec
une des plus belles vues au monde
c'est vraiment magique à l'histoire
j'ai fait d'énormes gratte avait cet
appel à rien grâce à sa fortune parce
qu'elle pourrait arrêter de travailler
mais à 55 ans il a décidé de se lancer
dans un nouveau défi
pascal voit toujours plus grand fini les
boulangeries de quartier il veut
s'attaquer à la grande distribution
alors il a racheté cette usine à
starbucks pour plusieurs millions
d'euros l'ancien petit boulanger
bordelais a décidé de partir à la
conquête de toute l'amérique du nord
[Musique]